people uh nyk rickster um rip of course
uh one
one of the homies uh and you too mark
man but it's been so long
being here now you know what i'm saying
it just it always feels good to come
back and talk tekken with your family
you already know what it is
oh my gosh the next match on the loser's
side
dial it wave with the josie resolve
going
up against el negro's leroy
well well this is the first time we're
seeing both of these characters here in
the tournament
uh on stream at least josie and oh leroy
this is uh this is gonna be interesting
because you know we both know that these
players use these characters
but to be able to pull them out here is
the start for their their character
matchup
let's see it let's see it
oh counter the follow up here this is
gonna hurt he's
gonna get the wall no just drop combo
that goes for the mid
oh i like this
to get away from the wall sidestep a
little bit uses the parry
uh-huh that goes in the hermes stance
just to let you know
it goes for that orbital i like the
spacing by dial it wave there
look at that nice wall rising knee able
to get the the momentum back pushing
again
on the 444 i can't believe he look he
sidestepped that that was crazy
yup that's a homing too that's what i
said i was like how did he just do that
he's good he's that boy good boy good
that
here we go follow up here at the wall as
well what's he going to do goes for the
ground pound
boom boom boom that boy told me he sized
up four four four from josie i said boy
you ain't side step no damn
side four that's four four four from
josie but you never sign except in your
life i guess i did i did sidestep it was
on the labels on the laboratory stage
with the scientists in the background
and stuff
oh man shout out to everyone that that
knows what's up if you caught that
you're a legend i'm telling you right
now
here we go has the wall positioning it
gets the punish here looking to close
things out daily wave
maybe getting the first round here oh
nice i like it here we go
josie fighting back
here goes for the orbital orbital once
again
oh get off of me nice
mm-hmm searching for this orbital right
now
wake up chad with the josie got a match
down back three
nice oh that was a very very there i
like it
okay look at this pressure from dylan
wave down back four down back three once
again this could be closing out and
negro going for the big mid right there
okay leroy the character switch once
again hit him with the footwork
the posture it's a poise here see my the
specialist
say check the footwork now look at the
hands yeah that's right
leroy getting the w once again uh i said
this earlier
but the character switches were
definitely a thing that could come from
el negro i've seen him play so many
different characters over the years i've
seen him play different characters in
tournament as well
and it's been working out going from the
kuni mitsu um and then of course we see
the switch now
to leroy it's all been working out do
you think daily wave is going to switch
to fenway that's my question here
anyway obviously his main main right do
you think the switch is coming
i think the switch is coming because i
think the the josie pick was
there for um a potential character
switch anyway
and i think that was meant to throw him
off right so i think now we're gonna get
to leroy
and i feel like it's a kind of a tight
situation because it's gonna be tough
considering you're going into game
number two
versus leroy and now you're gonna try to
pull out the business
that's why you gotta pull out you gotta
keep the briefcase on you you gotta be
willing
to go in the business form instantly in
a tournament situation i'm just saying
they were both trying to surprise each
other with their picks right it was like
he's not ready for my josie then he sees
leroy's like damn it
damn it i wasn't ready for that either
no that's what that's what happens
though man i feel like leroy is one of
those characters you just really have to
be careful
and just like falconrom right like you
have to understand how to fight that
character and i feel like it's
it's definitely and we've said this
across so many years at tekken 7.
it's more about how familiar you are
with the matchup because coming in no
no tekken player is going to be able to
you know safely defend 100
versus characters like fokker mom
especially you know on the first time
out but the more you fight them the more
you get used to it it definitely becomes
a lot uh easier as well as just for the
fact you get used to dealing with some
of the moves so
that's just how you have to fight the
matchup fighting the leroy now is
definitely something that i feel like a
lot more people have gotten used to and
it's part of the reason
we don't see that many leroys i think
that the fact is like
they've constantly made it a point to
try to keep leroy at a level
to where he's not going to be too
overwhelming and i think they've done a
good job
the orbital change thank you guys i
thank you so much because i'm i'm just
saying man like you just don't like it
when rip hits you with this i definitely
just don't like yeah that rip guy i just
don't like when he hit you with
and and i know you i know they're doing
the right thing because rip gets
increasingly more salty about it so
whatever you do to you know piss rip off
i'm
actually there for anyway including nerf
in his characters but uh when it comes
to
this right now i want to see what are
you going to do to kind of fight a leroy
especially one
from somebody like el negro who will
challenge you he will go into raw
you know herman stands just to see and
like i said before
dialet wave going for the switch and i
don't blame him because like i said you
really want to throw people you want to
keep people on their toes
that character switch was an attempt at
it i feel like leroy the great equalizer
uh definitely a good choice to kind of
counter pick the counter pick
round one counter pick the counter pick
like i counted
but this is this is home court advantage
oh this is feng stage
but but round three is a different thing
bro that's when you get the leroy
soundtrack bro
that's when the band come out like the
no limit army big damage on the wall
with the shoulder yo damn it make him
say
uh he said oh after that wall combo
oh my god that's supposed to be safe do
you see how
you see how fang holds his lip while
rising too
oh my god do you see how fang holds his
lip when he got hit in the mouth after
the punch perry hits
oh yeah he's gonna have to be careful
he's right by the wall too nice homing
attack
try to step away from the rage drive
they're unable to do it oh the barry
again
oh my god dude no and you could tell
right there uh it was really smart
battle negro he actually sidestepped
left delayed the rage drive a little bit
and that was the smartest thing he could
have did because could have been in
trouble could have got jabbed out of it
that's great awareness
counter hit combo conversion okay el
negro
uh uh no too low didn't get the follow
up down 4-1 and get it started excuse me
while rising one
counter hit full combo pickup no didn't
finish it though kind of goes for a
reset looking for a counter hit with the
tech
once again that herman stands the
turtles are lining up
the sidestep moves spins the blue gets
the back could've had big damage on the
wall side step four
the down three down four one dial away
down four one straight the double okay
oh let's go
the double ko let's go it's good that he
got around but he also gave a round to
el niro and now's negro now just one
round away
from eliminating thailand away from the
tournament
oh oh oh oh oh turning things up though
he's still continuing with that momentum
oh nice wrong punish
his song is playing though as long is
playing you can see the band in the
background
bang let him know how you feel about the
soundtrack let him know don't don't let
him get to the chorus that's when he
gets crazy and that's when he gets
that's
actually when he gets crazy because he
starts thinking about the neighborhood
bro
oh nice good stuff here dylan wave
looking to close it out
back for the fish hook we like to call
it look like i said before look let him
know how you feel about the song
with your hip hopping what is this
bang definitely looks like he'll call it
the hip hopping he's like what is this
the hip hopping
the pulse i know my heart's true
this block my man said i came back from
the east
when i'm not fighting leroy to this song
this song just be dropping bars man
my man said i came back from the east i
feel it in my heart i'm like bro
he said it's slow that's how you know he
meant it punish just goes for the
orbital
style wave still controlling though he
does have the lively but he's gonna have
to be careful especially
oh my god he's not dead though he's not
dead though gonna put him on the red
dress oh the walking stick three blind
mice
big damage i'm spinning the blue oh i
told you the boost up let me see it
steps on him erotic care package oh my
god it's the same move he ran
up hits him with them tracking mid hit
him with the footwork
huh huh check the hands yeah
lost your poise and control and just
like that
dylan wave out of the tournament but you
know he did uh he did put up the good
fight he did put up the good fight
no i can tell you right now i feel like
that match would have went a lot
differently
if we saw the fang right out of the gate
i feel
but that that counterpick of the counter
pick really came back to bite him in the
ass because
now he had to deal with a deficit when
he's already set on leroy i will say
this though if you're fighting leroy you
definitely want to use the main don't i
would not
unless you are proficient at the leroy
matchup
don't go in their plan man don't come in
there wearing your anime dress-up shirt
from high school when you're trying to
get this job done
you want to come in there full button up
you know what i'm saying
you want to come in with a new button up
maybe a good ass tekken shirt like the
ones we're wearing right now that you
can get
right now we gave you a little time to
get it i gave you a full break
to go get yourselves a good ass tekken
shirt